citizens of the reject Nation welcome to
another of our DC animated films this
one actually in the dcau as far as I
know John and I are confused one day
it's gonna make sense as told by you how
you feeling John I am super excited I'm
ready to get wet how are you going I am
ready to get turgid wet and Aquaman uh
neither of us have seen this one nope
this is our first that's gonna be a
theme across all these reactions you may
have caught on our intros we haven't
seen this no First Watch it's an
it's an in the order of the dcau so if
you'd like to watch more of these please
do subscribe hit that notification Bell
leave a comment let us know which of
these you've enjoyed the most which one
you want us to watch next we're going in
some sort of order we'll find out all of
us together we think and please do hit
that like button so we know that you did
in fact like this and most of all if you
want to watch this in order with us
without without edits without without
gaps we want to see our resting watching
fish's swim face which looks something
like this
become a patron for every moment queued
up from the start to the Finish you know
we can't play the actual movie over
there because Warner Brothers we're not
of the brothers we're not Brothers
wondering they can play it we cannot so
hit that patreon if you want to join us
for the entire journey and either way
let's kick it off with Throne of
Atlantis
new logo exciting
Aquaman's in the D he's earned it
getting that D getting that day very
important for the throne
deepest trench in the world I think
right
I'm a trench expert I mean obviously
James wants the trench ah if only is
that your son big fan of the Justice
League yeah he used to play with a toy
submarine I gave him but not anymore oh
World building Dad can't compete with
Heroes like Superman around
uh you're a real hero not all heroes
wear capes
sonar has inbounds sir impossible it's
open ocean for Miles computer has 15 no
22 separate inbound he counts very fast
how he got Captain that's right real
heroes do math
37. now 55 inbounds still on target this
guy is really good at Counting
they look like like what D minus ten
like people
engine room report taking water captain
oh oh angry Atlantean Zhang or is this
the trench like the Black Panther story
I wonder if that's what he was gonna
adapt could be oh I wouldn't put past
him this is California with an emergency
SOS
oh God what a bad way to go yeah SOS
responding to another SOS
drowning plus fear that's like the worst
knowing you're gonna bite at them
drowning yeah
avoid the ocean upon shortness of breath
yeah right heart racing and then boo hey
Jim Lee art I think ooh I think it's Jim
Lee art yeah it's definitely Jim Lee art
beautiful work great line work new 52
suit on the soups different belts no
undies outside the where are the under
wherefore art thou underway is I hope uh
James Gunn brings the undies back I
think that'll be a very good strong
visual of uh this hopeful Superman he
said no Origins but uh I do want to see
them for years how he chose those undies
I mean that's the only merch I want
shopping
STAR labs
that's right that's right this is
Colonel Trevor government liaison of the
Justice League
James Cameron's back hey Jimmy Kims
Justice League tested better
Justice League town for the boys there
was the super seven
hey not yet cyborg
okay continuity is a mess guys
what's happening oh okay I see what this
is nicely done we got Hoodwinked
no please just a little longer five
minutes more
oh that's that's sad I came by to see
how you were doing after the operation
as long as I had my brain in heart
attack I'll be all right well I guess
I'll check you later I guess I'll put
away my Robo brain and heart
[Laughter]
you should keep those you're right
the Navy wants our missiles back
I'll boom down there and check it out
myself
the others they don't really come in
at all
despite what you would like the world to
think Colonel Trevor there is no justice
league oh interesting second movie
already that
yeah that disparate
oh great shot with the table too yeah
the empty table the big long shadow
you ever feel alone oh
but I've learned a way to deal with it
watch Man of Steel
kiss and float into the sky which I
could probably only safely do with you
yeah all right yeah it's little things
you know yeah it's a good line though oh
yeah I wouldn't be able to resist that
come on now life sucks I've never
believed it before but I believe it now
no
hey there's another one over here okay
but I'm cutting you off after this one
Arthur there in the World is Carmen San
Diego
all these years all these years just so
hunting down Aquaman
I'm alone
we're talking
so I know you miss your dad but
oh I was gonna eat that then you're
gonna have to go through me first
I was hoping to fight before dinner let
it warm up hungry oh
come on man what these guys do they're
so coordinated hold up hold up
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's go
oh yeah
[Music]
oh geez back in the head wow
dang guys are murderers it's pretty cool
action brutal sound design
oh jeez man
it's exactly what we've been looking for
David we must confront him tonight maybe
we shouldn't out him here just yet
doctor we can approach him in the
morning is that All-State stand yeah was
it Andre Brower or Dennis Haysbert oh
that's the name I was like it's almost
actually turns out it's neither
thanks guys I needed to blow off some
steam yeah steam because you're a water
guy
[Laughter]
puns
oh cool are we so dense
what the hell are you
oh
wish I knew pal is this like Aquaman of
Steel
it's learning kind of feel that way
right now it definitely does
cool damn worried about you under all
this water my guy gets Rusty is that a
handprinted
oh Eerie
what the hell
now
oh no oh
the most damage
oh it's all right
spiky
ah
whoa they just wheeled boom tubes
already damn you don't take a bunch of
water with you when you do that we
didn't see him Landing though
foreign
[Music]
let me walk past my trauma wall here
keep these up to remind me why I punched
people who take lobsters contacted
everyone yeah Billy you came sure
these two love this
hey guys sorry um
not late
I'll bet you like Cuban food I know this
sick place
in Cuba
interesting inflection
I mean it worked
oh no yeah what's the what I was just
about to seal the deal Cyborg's got
something all hands on deck race here to
headquarters
we have a headquarters
is that Philly I think it is yeah he's
back Clark
yeah
this actually works ah
amazing that
oh I adore that oh it takes
and they're nice frames I mean purple
go with her hair it's nice accents this
is uh Lois Lane Diana Prince
oh that's some grip I work with Clark
closely oh my Diana is a diplomat so
this is an interview no it's a date
it's a wonder women go out with you at
all and Diana love your glasses
thanks
saddle yeah
what are they doing here I love you
Shazam oh Shazam fans yeah yeah they did
just materialize in the middle of the
street just very public good thing no
one's driving by well the bat's too good
for us now it's Batman he doesn't answer
Hales
I got a big light in the sky yeah he's
the most famous hail of all
it's like a signal of sorts scarecrow
don't pay me enough to deal with this
[__] you got that right he needs his own
intro there he is
[Laughter]
let's go
are you spooky
[Music]
well glue your schedule because you and
I are
[Laughter]
relaxed I got this hey there hinge dudes
I'll be handling your arrest today
[Music]
get us out of here
yeah Gotham citizens aren't probably
used to Space Magic
[Music]
wow the Hot Wheel in the Sky nice
[Laughter]
we're done here
are we who's the supplier for the
aerosol component of the fear toxin
what about something simple like where's
the Scarecrow bro I caught them for
you're welcome
you want to help do me a favor don't
don't yeah he's got bad business to get
into guys come on sir not appearing in
this film
no I'll be in the third act yeah they
need him he'll come back and save the
day I count four dozen unique hand
prints moving in sync four squadrons oh
never mind
he showed up walk us through your
assault
oh cool the s in my cave is black
because I'm edgy
it doesn't match but that's okay just
wanted to pop you know
these were warriors agreed
that looked like it hurt all over again
yeah seriously not the Sound Sensitivity
makes sense sound travels 4.3 times
faster underwater
whatever Mr barrel roll do a barrel roll
freeze
[Music]
and
gills as in mermaids as in Atlantis
where is this
wowie it sunk into the ocean but its
people were saved by the magic of the
king's Trident which turned them
irreversibly into creatures of the sea I
believe you of course he does
[Music]
Superman and I will go question Dr Shin
what should the rest of us do
find Atlantis
you know bring Atlantis to me so far
better portrayals of Superman and Wonder
Woman like from the leap I was about to
say yeah I'm enjoying them so far so
good we're about to strike first and
strike quickly my mother will not see it
as such she is yet to grasp the dangers
of the surfaces you have Prince arm
soon she'll have no choice the mutton
chops on orn yeah the the chops run
thick in that Aqua family
she's got so many thingama Bobbers it's
like crayon colored it's cool like I
like the texture of the the whites they
kill our race they poison our oceans we
must protect our people and attack as
long as I am queen you will preserve the
peace
at all costs oh
what of my other son have you seen
Arthur he is not yet ready for the
weight of the crown
he will learn at my side mirror bring
him to me at once you guys got this not
too far Arthur don't fall in
I can do it
oh
merman paw man
[Music]
it's an interesting moment I saw her
she left Arthur and she's not coming
back it's just you and me now son and
I'm not going anywhere and you are
schizophrenic we should see a doctor if
you're seeing women in the oceans
I like the way they're doing his story
here though like a whole origin yeah
yeah it is interesting considering the
last movie like Justice League bar
Aquaman and now he's getting like an
actual Spotlight yeah the rest of the
team does their thing it's cool yeah I
like it I like the World building
call me after you've made contact
congratulations David I could not have
found him without you
I've got an evil jacket on oh that's why
oh no good reveal that was cool payload
ready sir
Reef get Dr Shin and a half breathe my
warmest regards
don't be an aqua racist I mean it's
uncomfortable I like how giant his neck
is to balance out the helmet they're
like let's try to make this you know
physically sustainable he does a lot of
neck lifting
I must talk to you Mr Curry come back
later I'm really hungry right now and
not in a good way
how about your father
why did you say that name
no one skips trap day in this universe
in the game
trap City I want to be all traps just
I'm gonna lean enema traps you my boy
are the key to all of my research I'm
gonna I'm gonna let you in because I
just can't talk through a door anymore
oh no
hell
it's just to see Playing Tricks on you
boy
five assassin men
and they did not just Gore your doors
they fight like fishermen yeah they do
I always feel bad for the lighthouse and
every adaptation right such a beautiful
place to live it's the Bruce's parents
of Aquaman Batman has pearls Superman
that says Krypton he loses the
lighthouse yep
foreign
houses left so many ships are gonna
crash now because of you guys
Arthur Curry is under my protection by
order of Queen Atlanta
[Music]
should turn the water ice
maybe cold
oh that's cool
[Music]
Follow My Lead I am an investigative
reporter you know
journalism's dead
we need to avenge journalism
you don't destroy someone's work and
then let them live to recreate it
don't touch anything
someone fed these fish recently
hahaha
that's great Thomas Curry begging Dr
Shin for help with his son Arthur Shin
suspects Curry's son is half Atlantean
invoke the emergency protocol oh no this
attack tells us what we already know
surface World wants us dead
Perhaps it is time for our worlds to
come together have Manta arrange a
meeting between myself and this Justice
League I will broker a piece with them
in person I hope you make it there yeah
uh your mother met and fell in love with
your father that Union resulted in your
birth she could neither wedge her father
nor raise a halfling child
heartbroken she returned to lead her
people
it's interesting how close this was to
the movie getting released yeah similar
what is it
this was our King's Royal garb now it is
yours
oh my dude hey thanks for that field
data I'm still working on a patch to
quiet the servos Sarah I can't talk
right now
oh Sarah it's like your dad come on man
coordinates attached find Arthur Curry
fast on it he's looking for Fairyland
the last suit you'll ever wear armor up
I felt like there was something wrong
with me and now some mermaid comes out
of the sea and tells me my mother is
alive and I'm the future of some
Fairyland I've never seen
yes I was waiting for that that's cool
um
the trench yes
whoa nice can you eat these guys like
you would a fish probably take a sushi
make a little yeah nice little roll out
but they're now in Reverse
that's a curry
I'm the Flash
yes wow nice
oh nicely done
my man
yes
Superman damn
Beacon Arthur if I had a chance to save
my world and meet one of my own race
even for a moment
that would be enough
let's do this Arthur
just makes fun of train traps go to the
gym
king of traps no
it's all I see king of trap Lantus trap
cities about this movie your brother
Arthur can Bridge the peace between
Atlantis and the surface your judgment
is compromised you refuse to attack the
surface because you have a son there a
bastard Elder son
son you who spelled Atlantean blood and
blamed it on the surface
I see you
get out of my way
damn good I am queen and war is not in
my plans
yeah I don't like that close up yeah it
was just a matter of time
it is in mine
oh dude
[Music]
that's gonna fill up the whole chamber
yes the worst way to start so tell me
what you like
it's time you found out for yourself oh
[Music]
tell me why is the Royal City deserted
our brave men and women have gone to
prepare for war not possible the queen
would never allow this our Queen Is Dead
foreign
killed by a surface dweller
prove it whoever did this will pay
welcome bastard
killed her I did
You Can Count yourself fortunate bastard
at least our mother won't be the
impediment to your life that she was to
mine ocean real son of a [__]
what's up
damn
feel my power success
only royalty can wield the magic of the
Trident ah interesting offer them to the
horrors of the dark Trench oh no
oh cool all of these ruins I was like
how are they gonna keep them alive like
Green Lantern would drown immediately ah
these little bubbles
I mean I was already wondering like
how's Wonder Woman breathing down here
Amazonian I'm like I get the magic space
guy and the Kryptonian guy and cyborg
has his mouth thing but
the thing is scary and I have questions
yeah
the cthulhu's the mother of all tidal
waves is heading for the Eastern
seaboard
is that Metropolis secondary
confirmation
oh good oh good yeah ETA to impact 20
minutes how are the three of us going to
evacuate entire cities
we can't people are going to die oh no
break out your bat tsunami wall or
something that shark repellent can only
do so much
only royalty can wield the magic of the
Trident
oh come on
[Music]
oh buddy rise to your full potential
Cthulhu
oh
my God
yeah clearly didn't work out so well
immediately nah soups will come back
whale friendly done nicely done
if only James Cameron had directed A
Aquaman film oh if only how's that joke
and Entourage that would have been so
real
yeah Bonk
remodeled the trench
you're welcome I talked to Fish now and
they actually listen I'm gonna stop my
evil half brother from destroying the
surface world you want to come it would
be my honor it's an interesting it's
very different like characteristics he
just changes like no I got jokes
oh oh
good call
I mean it's a little late I I you guys
could have spotted that a little earlier
you had 20 minutes
oh oh oh
[Applause]
[Music]
he wants his entrance Moses
kill the humans
humans oh boy
[Music]
geez
whoa
every time flash it's just it's just so
good
yes yeah
just boxes yeah
John Henry irons are we oh
oh sweet out of nowhere let's do this
yep nice what to do still that's
fantastic damn
that's cool Green Lantern power vacuum
yes
I just love that he's got a little perch
to sit on it's like Gundam Wing vacuum
just vibing out
Jimmy Olsen's here he's always on the
case but isn't he supposed to be a CIA
operative he's already dead run Jimmy
I would not want to be on her bad side
[Laughter]
oh Megalodon oh we just ate him yup damn
that's how you use those Aquaman powers
hahaha
that's that's great all that build up
and then Megalodon
this madness form King om traitor
sees her
make her watch my Triumph
let us see whose magic is stronger I can
see your Schwartz is his biggest mine
damn
oh these are your Guardians this will be
easier than I ever dreamed
oh
no
all right kill kill him gotta kill him
kill him
I admire your determination but the
Trident is mine to command wench nah who
went way to throw the winch in there
damn it
you should have done like a Green
Lantern fishnet or the vacuum yeah
oh damn horm can even cook soups we're
not going to win by hitting them as hard
as we can
bro do not turn this into a learning
moment
he killed his own mother does that help
face me arm yeah come on art step up
pretty good with the bow staff
whoa
oh cyborg oh
come on Victor
do tase me bro
Lantern said orm confessed to killing
his mother to us he lied to his people
but you saw it and you know what that
means
he is just good at Goring people he is
that trident is useful Gorham
killed her ideas this I ran the song
through her myself
you did do that villainy wait just
deception is their service magic liar I
was there when Oren boasted to the
murder of our Queen I did this for you
you wow nice
you need a light to guide you in the
darkness people of Atlantis
what are you doing
becoming a beacon he's a lighthouse
oh
[Music]
Bend in the knee
okay just immediately you're my queen
now didn't the end of the other one have
like a threat from Atlantis I thought it
ended with like imma come for you
seems okay
how does it feel
it feels good
but we can pick it up tonight
over dinner
I'd like that
yeah that's what I'm talking about
victory victory
yeah and the comic logo he has found his
place
are you free later
if I can find my glasses
[Music]
we need to consider solidifying this
team like weekly meetings
I'm in
a man yeah well online they're calling
him oh
I hate that they always do I should keep
a foothold in both worlds besides it'll
help repair relations if I'm seen
helping out
through that perhaps
perhaps you should stay behind me I'm
the one with the Trident perhaps you
should stay behind me
[Music]
oh yeah
cool yeah
look at that lineup
not bad I like this much better than the
other uh War One than the Justice League
we were like this a lot that was that
was good I did like this a lot as well I
I thought something you mentioned
earlier on the uh the way they had his
story separate and then the Justice
League already formed was really
interesting because they were able to do
like a Justice League Sequel and an
Aquaman origin in a way that didn't feel
like the only time I noticed the
everyone fight him at once was the end
but then they were really clever to make
it an intellectual thing like they
didn't have them like because the first
movie ends with let's all team up and
unite together had been really like
lackluster if we were like we were just
missing Aquaman like yeah I was afraid
of that but instead they had to be like
they had to outsmart him it was Rosario
Dawson I meant to call it out
that's great uh I I was sitting there a
lot of the time going man I bet I Wonder
Woman sounds just like uh Rosario Dawson
so not Michelle Monaghan this time I
guess not yeah so uh yeah like that
really impressed me there was a couple
writing things that that drought drove
me a little crazy uh like there was
times where like they would repeat but
in the opposite direction like like she
was like do you really think the only
way to have safety is to kill everyone
you will watch me kill everyone for the
safety I was like why are we like and
and like little things but overall like
a much tighter uh story and I didn't
love the the Superman
um like he was he only had like eight
lines and one of them was like oh shove
that fork so far down is like Superman's
not vengeful yeah but otherwise like it
was a better characterization of the two
of them I thought so yeah like that one
line yeah anytime Superman gets like
outwardly like I'm gonna beat the [__]
out of you or something to that extent
I'm a little bit like is that soups but
this one definitely didn't
stand out as much as the Justice League
War one where I was like this guy seems
like he had a different guy like most of
the time he seemed like he had his
good-natured clarkness I feel like yeah
that that came back yeah and and I was
gonna ask actually like when they have
the date him and Diana and then Lois
shows up like what is the what exactly
is so they really tried to shoehorn in
and they've tried a number of times to
have one Roman and Superman have
relationship I think it's just because
like sure they both have powers so like
the when the new 52 launched they did
have them together and I guess that's
like you know piecing together some of
that but it never like works like it
it's like it just doesn't feel right and
even here it kind of doesn't feel like
right yeah I mean I don't know there's
something so quintessential about Clark
and Lois and Humanity the humanity yeah
it's like the link to humanity rather
than the link to something you know
god-like yeah I feel like Batman are
friends but Jimmy's his best friend so
like making Lois his partner is as
important as Jimmy being the best friend
so if you have that'd be like if his
only friends were Batman and Wonder
Woman it kind of keeps him out of the
humanity which is honestly kind of the
Betrayal yeah no I I can I can see that
yeah and it is here and I I at least
appreciated that it wasn't as extreme to
that degree and Wonder Woman as well
like in the Justice League War was a bit
you know it was much like sort of
sassier and edgier than I ever associate
Wonder Woman with I liked here that she
when she was a warrior the Betrayal was
like I'm proud of you for standing up
for your plate your people I will do the
same it wasn't like my people are better
I'm gonna be mad like yeah it didn't
feel so like aggro it felt like we are
both Warriors and like I have to do this
like there was an honor to it yeah yeah
yeah yeah and that's that sense of you
know slight fish out of wateriness in
that you know you are a warrior in a
human society for the most part
one giant flaw for me sure
why oh why oh why would arms stop the
wave from killing millions of people and
then like fight on the land dwellers
terms they could have had one line of
dialogue where he was like I'll beat you
with your own game
Bell Rev
what do we got
oh I am a royal blood
at least to give him a pool that's nice
you will let me speak
brother
I am Lex Luthor yes you are I have a
proposition for you
I was listed in the voice credits and I
wondered why I didn't notice that's
crazy oh that's really funny
yeah but like one line of dialogue is
you know I'll be at your own game the
arrogance form or another line of
dialogue is they're able to thwart the
wave but they're still gonna have to
fight but like without even
acknowledging it we build up all this
tension through the second the late
second act of this wave crashing down
and then they're like no and like you
just like what yeah and I get that it's
you know big and impressive and imposing
to be like I'm going to part the seas
and demonstrate my control over the
oceans and and yet at the same time I
feel like yeah that does lessen the
impact because you know not everyone's
gonna see this a lot of people have left
and if you even say the arrogance line
then that shows the the Splendor and
then also like your own game I'm gonna
War your way land dwellers yeah yeah I
can beat you in the sea and on and on
land yeah and that's something that
would be intimidating if you see someone
invading you from their Turf and like
taking you over on yours it's more
likely that you're gonna like give up
yeah so like I just I just I was really
bothered for like five minutes I had to
shake it I was like this is dumb okay
we're back yeah I could see that I mean
I guess I guess it maybe paints you into
a corner like how do they figure out
what to do with all the water but even
then I feel like with the the team like
you know if you do flood the city I feel
like the team could still probably
figure out how to undo all that or just
don't like or just have like you know
Green Lantern push it out or just don't
yeah
but overall like this felt way more
Justice League and also I really was
impressed that it was able to do
something different with the team
simultaneously of Aquaman like that was
an impressive tone to balance like a
Justice League 2 an Aquaman one it
didn't feel like you tucked them away
like there were separate missions that
didn't feel like side missions yeah
really cool tone yeah and it felt pretty
well-rounded it felt pretty breathable
because I mean this is a compact movie I
mean this is I feel like by a couple
minutes one of the shorter ones we've
seen and it didn't feel like I remember
what I was talking about
Justice League War feeling kind of kind
of compacted a little bit like yeah like
there's a bunch of happening and there's
not really a ton of uh meat on the
character bones and whatnot and here I
was sitting there thinking like I
glanced at the at the clock at one point
and I was like oh well like you know I
thought we were way further into this
movie than we were in a good way where I
was like oh cool like somehow in an hour
and 10 12 minutes they've still managed
to make this feel you know like paced
like an actual story give it some room
to have those more contemplative moments
with Arthur as you're watching him get
on his feet like I I really loved you
could split this movie in half and you
have like a nice gradual adventure of
the Justice League you know figuring out
how and why to come together and
addressing that thing of like yeah
they're they're a team in the public eye
but they're not really a team yet and so
watching them sort of grow as a team on
the one side was fun while you also
watch Arthur sort of pick up the
wreckage of his life and find purpose
and even hearing the super seven like I
like that there's a clear Line in the
Sand of like we're not a team we don't
see each other two Justice League is a
United Team I really liked how clear
they made that yeah absolutely and
nobody ever likes their given name from
the people I just once I won the next
time somebody gets their their name
moment I want them like this is pretty
good
because I'm sure yeah
and I like the the voice cast overall I
like that the main cover art looks like
Tom Cruise in the 80s with blonde hair
no that's like Top Gun one Tom Cruise
brows and nose right there and they did
a nice thing uh uh too with that where
like you know he even the little Easter
eggy moments that are uh you know like
oh here's how he gets the suit like I I
that can oftentimes be cheesy but I like
the way they did it here where it's like
he's got the full suit with all the
armor on it and then as he's like this
isn't me he takes it off and it becomes
the suit that we all know so well yeah I
really dug that yeah so this was 2015.
when did the Aquaman movie come out was
it 2016
it wasn't that long it wasn't eight
years or seven years ago find out
Aquaman 2018. 2018. okay so two years
later Dean Arthur Curry my man okay so
this was close oh Sean asthma's Billy
Batson of course it was yeah you got
Jerry O'Connell Clark Kent solid yeah
okay Jason MRA back to crushing does
Bruce Wayne Shemar Moore is back I feel
like he's done a cyborg before right I
think so interesting that's a good okay
Harry Lennox was black man so there you
go yeah okay was didn't he uh jump up
into the Snyder verse I think he did as
Martian Manhunter wasn't it yeah wasn't
that Harry Lennox two years later yeah
uh yeah so I I mean I I enjoyed this
more than the uh the other one in this
specific series just because it did feel
like the characterizations were a little
more of a blend of this new one and
their their counterpart yeah yeah yeah
this split the difference I think pretty
nice I'm very curious where it goes with
those characterizations like forward
like this voice cast this universe this
Multiverse they've built yeah totally
and yeah yeah to see as it moves forward
I'm wondering if it becomes maybe more
intentionally connected connectable or
something like that or more consistent
like I'd be curious to know as we get
further into these and especially thank
you all for you know we were pretty
aware that that yeah like uh assault and
Arkham is is outside of this continuity
but yeah like within this continuity I'd
be curious to know yeah what the plans
were when they realized like okay we are
going to do this big connected sequence
of movies and yeah then how the
characters are affected you know in
their portrayals by that because it is
interesting like especially yeah coming
directly out of uh Justice League War
it's like if you watch them back to back
I have to feel like the the characters
would feel a bit different yeah and also
the end of Justice League War With The
Atlantis thing I thought that was like
an offensive like the end of the
post-credits scene felt like he was
already he was yeah just like coming up
and he was like coming back yeah yeah so
that must be an odd thing to
back-to-back it's yeah it's an
interesting yeah I guess they they kind
of loosely together yet what he was
going to be doing they're like we didn't
really think of the the overall arch of
that story when we did that post credit
scene we were just like oh we gotta
establish the atlanteans are coming and
and yeah and then why Aquaman was
nowhere to be found and this was a way
better way to do it I love like I said a
few times the the two stories coming
together like this was the move also if
you've got Michael Rosenbaum you make
him Lex Luthor drift leader Michael
Rosemont what are you doing one day was
he only available one day you got the
best Lex in the game in the house ah
yeah he'll get his time in the sun James
gun you bring back Rosie you put him in
that ball shave that man's head you put
him in Multiverse man if they do if
anyone should come from the TV world
it's it's I think he's the best Lex of
all time you heard me Gene Hackman oh
you work out Gene he heard you he
watches he watches
I love Eugene Hackman yeah he's the best
and we also got a little John Henry iron
we did that was good you called it
immediately yeah
so far to hyphenate the name you know
and it's gonna be but at the same time I
was just like oh what a cool thing and
and that it doesn't have to become it's
just a guy yeah he'll he could show up
later and I'll be even more psyched if
that happens I like when they do that
like World build without having to be a
thing yeah totally yeah I dug this this
was a lot of fun if you guys enjoyed
please do leave a comment let us know
what you thought uh this was up there
for me and this definitely I was a
little concerned uh with like being kind
of iffy on the characterizations of a
few characters in the first one this has
me very excited for whatever we get into
next very very excited and then I know
the out of continuity Arkham absolute
July so these have been fantastic so we
would love to keep doing them so please
the best way for that to happen is for
you to like subscribe and share and
notification Bell to do YouTube things
I'm out of words uh John always a
pleasure always a pleasure sir thanks
for having me with you and and hey
before we skedaddle you want to do some
Patriot Edition
Adelia Chamberlain you
belong are the one who keeps my Discord
not in disarray oh in a rake but that's
called Discord so I was playing with
words there you are a champion and we
appreciate you feeling so ideal tastic
oh do good work oh yeah you just stay
invested dude you care about the fandoms
she's like the mirror of your Discord
you're Aquaman she's like hey man you
gotta rise
I only get in there like twice a week
but she's always ready yeah because
I'm just I got a lot to do sometimes I'm
off Planet sometimes I'm here sometimes
about other channels but Delia's always
keeping it down hell yeah that is very
much appreciated thank you Patron you're
you're our Valentine for this month
collectively all of us here at the
reject Nation you're our value this is
February isn't it it is only took me a
little over a week to put that together
yeah man Black History Month and
Valentine's Day here all about love and
figuring out equality one goddamn in
America figure it out at a time
I love you Delia catch you next month
foreign